[Music]
our Series a more perfect union
highlights how the things we have in
common far outweigh our differences
today we look at the power of the
written word Common Core standards no
longer require students to learn cursive
but supporters of long handwriting
refused to let it die 11 states either
require or encourage the teaching of
cursive in public schools and since 2017
a total of 10 states have considered
legislation to add cursive writing to
the curriculum Omar Villafranca visited
a school in Dallas to see how loops and
tails are connecting people in a digital
world this is the end of the thought
these third graders at Good Shepherd
Episcopal in Dallas are learning a lost
art they're practicing cursive by
writing letters to their pen pals my
third grade teacher taught me cursive
writing it's almost a foreign language
for today's younger generation I got
used to it hard to read and harder to
write Tim Allen's daughter is in the
class wouldn't it be fun for the
children to begin to learn how to read
letters and perhaps get the thrill of
getting a real letter in the mail first
thing we're going to do is look at the
letter that is up on the screen he came
up with the pen pal idea and shared it
with her teacher Karen Gunter you got a
letter today after he sent a letter in
cursive to his daughter away at camp and
she couldn't read a word he had written
so she was mad at me well why are you
mad at me we your letter I didn't say
anything bad in the letter no you wrote
it in that funny writing mallet overseas
several retirement homes and knows a lot
of people who still use that funny
writing so he helped pair up students
with several seniors like 75 year old
Suze Stanley it's difficult for me to do
texts and emails or texts anyway because
there's so many shortened abbreviated
things that I don't know what they have
don't forget the dates at the top of
your pages Shue was matched up with nine
year old Samantha Mosely and the pair
instantly hit it off on paper I feel
like I'm actually talking to
this is make me like like to write a lot
more
this is excellent excellent penmanship
third-grade teacher Karen Gunter says
the cursive lesson also allows her to
teach grammar along with the mechanics
of writing what does a capital D look
like and it's one of the only time she
knows the students are paying attention
when we're writing the letters they are
quiet but during other times in class oh
no they it's me some of them never shut
up eighty year old retired writer Nancy
Miller was worried she wouldn't have
anything to talk about with her
nine-year-old pen pal a hon Jane and in
the very first paragraph or two he says
I'm a Dallas Cowboys fan and my favorite
players Dez Bryant and I thought wow we
have a connection right away it turns
out Nancy and ahan both have strong
opinions on their beloved Dallas Cowboys
so what are you writing to her about now
is this better than text messaging is it
better than email how come guys in text
messaging you don't have a visual of the
person but in the letters you do after a
few months exchanging letters the
students finally got a chance to meet
their cursive correspondent sue and
Samantha are now more than pen pals oh
she's just friend for you she said
mister she's just wonderful I got to
meet someone new and not just writing to
them and short letters and stuff I
actually got a friendship with her
in a world of constant emails texts and
direct messages the kids say there's
nothing like that funny writing to help
keep friends connected for CBS this
morning
Omar Villafranca Dallas I love that
story
and it's more via Frank I know there's a
lot about the cursive but I also think
there's just a lot about the letter
writing yeah you know what I mean the
last time and you know think about
Barbara Bush passing and all the letters
that were exchanged between her and
George HW Bush beautiful thoughtful love
letters right on many levels I like that
story for the letter writing that you
said and just the beauty of cursive
writing and what the little boy said
gives you the visuals of the person with
the text message you don't have that you
always write in cursive on your nose it
has to be liberabit and intentional
which is not a bad thing to be in our
rush story nice